[music]
at night I got up just went to the kitchen I
heard a light pop, I thought I probably
tried it as always, I went to bed and in
the morning I saw in the News All those
left there was
nothing, no windows were shaking, nothing a
light pop, as if in the distance somewhere
early in the morning
an attack in advance again  version of
unmanned vehicles, unfortunately, the
effective
work was immediately organized by the forces of the
Ministry of Emergency Situations of
our Main Directorate of Sevastopol, the
headquarters is now working, presently,
presently, the fire has actually been
localized, those barrels, tanks
that could have been saved, they are all now
cut off from the fire, are being cooled by
fire crews and are bringing
in fact, problems of some situations
that may arise in connection with this
incident,
this will not affect the supply of fuel in Sevastopol in any way; an
operational reserve is stored here that does
not involve
ordinary life in any way. As for the emissions
that arise into the air
due to the combustion of petroleum products, now
Rospotrebnadzor  PTC measurements are being carried out,
first of all, Ukraine will be
[music]